you write in the book cynics like to lie
and call themselves realists hoping for
positive outcomes can thus be dismissed
as being naive or utopian
can you elaborate on this point just
like you said right now I mean
it seems like a
I don't know if it's a fundamental
characteristic of our society today or
just societies throughout history but
there is a cynicism you write in the
Soviet Union it was a really that's a
deep cynicism but that was good at the
end yeah
um and but there is a cynicism today as
well at least in like public discourse
yes why does it happen and how can we
fight it
um I think it is easy
to be like everything sucks
uh you know I had my friend Lux um she
was a uh a vlogger and she was an author
she had this great line because you know
we worked in media and she's like if
you're at a party and someone starts
talking about a new app or website and
you don't know anything about it just
say oh I was on that for a while it
sucked and that's all you need to say
I'm like look that's a great line but I
I think it is and especially I'm sure
you had to you experienced this as well
with your family I certainly did with
mine there is this idea especially in
Russian culture but in American culture
to some extent as well where if you have
Aspira aspirations I remember there was
this show called Russian dolls it was
oh I just got it like the matrushka okay
I just got it that's the name okay the
show is called Russian dolls it was
about Brighton Beach which is the
Russian Jewish neighborhood in Brooklyn
it was supposed to be their version of
Jersey Shore it was a lifetime and it
had no ratings and I remember the last
four episodes they had to burn them so
they just ran it through like 8 A.M to
10 a.m one day and there was this one
scene where the when the girls I forgot
her name probably Natalya and she'd been
in college
and she had been
wondering what she wanted to major in
right and this story was so perfect I'm
sure I've told it before and she took an
aptitude test and she went with her mom
to get like mani pedis or something and
she goes mom you know I've had like 80
Majors I didn't know what I wanted to do
and she goes I took this app to test it
really made sense to me I am gonna go to
law school I want to be a lawyer and
it's something I enjoy and the first
thing out of her mom's mouth is how are
you gonna pay for it and the girl and I
really related because if you didn't
have this Russian upbringing you watched
it you would think her reaction was
completely insane she just lost it just
screaming she's like people pay for law
school all the time I'll figure out a
way why is your first reaction to look
for a problem why is your first response
to be like oh what are you sure you've
thought this through I have been
struggling with one problem for years
what I wanted to do for a living and now
like as soon as I solve this one big
problem of identity your first reaction
is like let's find a new problem why is
that your instead of let's figure out
how we're gonna pay for it and that kind
of approach is so
uh deadly and it it gnaws at you and I
always I don't like giving people advice
because I'm cool the hell am I and also
if I don't know the context of the
problem I'm not informed enough to give
advice but this is piece of advice that
I do for Comfort giving if you are
someone who has around you people who as
soon as you have any accomplishment or
any hope that their first reaction is to
be like well what about this you have to
get rid of them or sit them down maybe
give them a chance because that is
something that is such so demoralizing
and it drains you and it's like you know
the example I've used all the time all
the time all the time I say if you want
to be an author right you can go to any
bookstore and look at all the shitty
shitty books like the white pill and you
could say to yourself I could be this
shitty author you don't have to be
having right so people should buy your
book just to know which it doesn't take
much it really does not take much shitty
writing is all about
and boring yeah you could just pick a
random random period in history and just
write a bunch of crap about it yes and
put a pretty stamp on the cover and just
go it was pretty yeah yeah but I mean
like like for you right like not you
don't I don't mean you left batteries by
the Wolves the wolf Bots there's lots of
stand-up comedians who aren't Jerry
Seinfeld yeah right if you want to be a
podcaster you don't have to be Joe Rogan
you could be someone who's got a medium
audience and are enjoying it so like the
idea that like something has to be you
have to be a massive Superstar or your
failure is also ridiculous but that's
cynicism
I mean you can even be a failed comedian
like Dave Smith uh yeah I don't
um this generic name I came up with as
an example
um I think he has like a podcast of some
kind he said I like it yeah not very
funny I don't know why you would call
himself a comedian but you he's being
ironic
um don't you think yeah so even even
then you could do something special I
remember what you did with me in the
movie theater what's that
I don't is oh you continue can you
explain the jokes because I can't oh I'm
not explaining jokes I'm wearing
lipstick it's not enough now I remember
what you did to me in a movie theater
and you wore lipsticks that night too
not when I was done
people for sure will think this this
feels like a gay porn
like like a very long intro because
we're not wearing pants yes there's many
reasons why this feels like this and the
outfits and just everything about this
uh how would you know I my friend I have
stories I thought I don't have friends
they're all suspiciously named either
Lex or Lux or some variation like you
lack complete creativity
just like in the writing or locks yeah
it's it's like you you didn't even use
like a thesaurus for your book the same
words over and over and over uh the the
sad thing about the cynicism is like I
don't think it's just a Russian thing I
I think the people let me just because I
didn't finish what you were saying
earlier in America it's not just a
Russian thing in American culture if you
have like a sitcom or a musical it's
regarded as less legitimate than a drama
right like if something's got to be
about someone's struggling or someone's
suffering whereas this is like a joyous
happy story like maybe something like
Pixar right like sure they have conflict
and they're going for something but it's
overall the background the universe is
taking in is very joyous and happy that
is regarded artistically as less
legitimate than something which is dark
and and the background is Despair and
that very subtly sends a very to me
pernicious message that the you know
that what's real is Despair and
happiness is the aberration and I think
if you have that as your mindset you're
setting yourself up for maybe not
failure but certainly not happiness
yeah but that that's in the the figures
the ideas that the culture elevates but
at the local personal life of parents
and teachers that still happens a lot in
Russia and here just my whole life
especially because I'm a weirdo
I've been kind of told to
um
basically be less weird
be uh
um
there's a kind of
sense and where there's a certain path
you're supposed to take in life
and every time you have a little bit of
success on those very specifically
defined paths you're pushed to do more
and more and more on those paths as
opposed to celebrating the full
complexity of the weirdo that each one
of us is and I certainly am and I just
teachers even friends
and certainly family
have constantly been
um very cynical about
um my aspirations my dreams and so on
um
I I think that actually created a deeply
self-critical engine in my brain
that I think It ultimately was
productive
because it was also
um
balanced by just an internal maybe
through genetics thing I have of
optimism about the world of just seeing
the beauty in the world but it is weird
looking back how much the how much
people that love me were trying to uh
bring me down yeah it's so strange it's
also very hurtful for me because when I
graduated college it was important for
me to be self-made and not take money
from my family and I remember my grandma
this was a huge argument an ongoing
argument and one time she you know as we
relieve as she was leaving my house she
slipped money in under the door and I
threw it out and it made me so angry
um or like one year for my birthday she
gave me I think like 500 which was a lot
of money you know when you're like 22 or
23 and I was so pissed because that
told me that they didn't believe that
I'd be able to feed myself or make it on
my own and I understand their their
mindset but it's like
I'm not I wasn't you know I never was
never hungry like maybe I couldn't I
remember I'd have to wait on the subway
because I couldn't afford a cab
um so but that was a sacrifice I had to
make you know I had to wait that half
hour so it was a huge source and remains
a source of enormous uh tension and
contention and I think also I'm sure
speaking to your upbringing in their
minds unless you're going into an office
you can't pay the rent it doesn't make
sense
um so but there's just like you said
forget the office forget all that no
matter what
there's always whatever you accomplish
in life you always do you're always uh
negative about your current position
you always come up with another problem
just like you said it's like a
self-generating problem box yeah I
remember I didn't speak to my dad for a
few years then I'm like let me give this
guy another chance and in that time
period Harvey pikar the author of uh
subject of American Splendor of the
movie and author of the series comic
books he and I became friends and he was
writing a graphic novel about me
and when I met with my Dad I'm like oh
uh someone's writing a book about me and
he goes I know so and it was one of
those moments where I'm like wow you're
an [ __ ] and not the kind of [ __ ] I
am you're just like not a good person
and I don't know or really at this point
care what the motivation or if there was
no motivation with the visceral
emotional reasoning for that but that
kind of thing is something I
you know much later now in life have
absolutely no tolerance for well my in
my own private life I try to forgive and
love those people but it is uh there
have been a few in my life like this and
I think they are they are incredible
people if you allow yourself to see it
but they're flawed and so
I tried to forgive them that said it is
true that uh the people that are close
to you especially family have a
disproportionate psychological effect on
you yeah you have to be very careful
having them in your life too much like
one thing is to love them
and the other is to actually you know
allow yourself to flourish surround
yourself with people that help you
flourish and like you said the advice
there is is really powerful especially
early on to have people that believe in
you in whatever crazy Big Dreams you
have they pat you on the back and say
you got this kid